[Applause]
quiet
silence so who was that dude who
wandered in nude earlier this week we
showed you a clip of a man who
accidentally video bombed a TV interview
with political commentator Dick Morris
let's see it again well I think Trump is
going to score a huge Victory I think
the media is going to try to downplay it
because as you correctly said they're
basically supporting um uh Ron they're
basically supporting
H now like anyone who saw this we had so
many
questions Dick Morris declined to give
us a comment so we were left to
speculate on what the hell was going on
here where was he exactly who was that
man why was he in his underpants could
Dick Morris have been taken hostage by a
retired
plumber and why can't that plumber
afford a sports bra what is going on I
need to know what you think so they're
getting ready to work out just a workout
Greg just a little Greco Roman wrestling
with your favorite workout buddy nothing
to see here and he he's coming for like
that's not like another room is that
like the garage I don't know what's
going on he looks like he just worked
out but for the first time
ever by the way you only put on this
type of shirt when you're about to be
arrested
yes but after we did the segment the man
the myth the legend got in touch with
me and he's joining us tonight to tell
us exactly what
happened please
welcome Doug
diio so Doug how's your week
going yeah that's great that's just
great beautiful I love it they weren't
underwear first of all they were shorts
I'm in Florida you wear shorts in a tank
top
okay how did this happen what
happened all right so I'm with Dick
Morris all the time I'm his guy you know
I set up the the backrop backdrops for
him and when I set it up he was going to
do the the pole thing in Iowa and I said
dick you got to put the the the camera
on an angle you got to put on an angle
cuz I'm going to be coming in and out of
the out of the house and of course when
I walked and I open the door and I saw
he was on I go I could shut the door and
then it' be like some freak dude open
the door shutting the door hey so better
so I just walked in and then later on it
goes I
go first of
all first of all the social
media put me out there as oh this guy's
dick Morris's gay friend the pool boy
whatnot I was upstairs with my
girlfriend I got to say she's fraking
hot as could be upstairs having a nice
time it was great I'm telling you then
working on my motorcycle because I got
to work up my motorcycle you know I'm
not and I walked in I go all right dick
he let me tell you Dick Morris is
absolutely you guys know him he's a
genius he's politically he's the most
unbelievable guy around but he's like
Rainman you know he can't screw life bu
it but it's one of the nicest guys my
best friend you know and I told him put
the camera on an angle and he didn't so
what am I going to do this is life yes
it
is was um was Dick annoyed because I
kept calling him all day I must have
called him seven eight
times I was there when when you called
and he said you called me five times and
I can I got a contract with Newsmax I go
dick you could have been a little nicer
about that you know nothing for nothing
go h going to do all right so but I
called you
because you know the social media they
just went and my friend from from uh
Manhattan calls me up Maddie goes hey
douggie I don't know they're talking
some bad stuff about you okay you got to
do something about this I said ah what's
the big deal what are you going to
do
on you know what's amazing is if I never
heard your voice by just looking you in
the video I would predict this is
exactly how you would
sound do
you do you have any um have you thought
about like turning this into some kind
of commercial for profit
Venture I could see coffee mugs
coasters t-shirts I got the perfect face
I got the perfect face for radio I'm on
I'm on the Dick Morris show on Sunday
12: to 2 uh the dick moris show I'm on
with him oh okay okay so you're kind of
like we have a good we got a good yeah
so uh do you plan on uh um kind of like
intruding in other uh Zoom TV
appearances I think you should make it a
regular
thing I'm thinking I'm going to do that
I was actually think or bring different
people in yes you know my my tall friend
my short friend other different people
that'll do it that'll be good so you
could tell you could tell my accent I'm
from yonas New York
yes hey did you um did you uh do you
have you ever met president Trump you
work you worked at Mar Lago right yes I
I I'm his artist I've been
restoring uh all the murals at maralago
form and uh we talk a lot I haven't seen
him in in a while but last year I was
there a lot and I'd see him almost every
morning and he'd walk around Dick Morris
says you know he likes you because you
talk
like he's going to not like that he's
not going to like
that wellist dou we' love to have you on
again you could probably be like maybe
our fashion
correspondent yeah oh you
like Oh you mean with the the the wife
beater got it oh by the way and by the
way your glasses yeah where'd you get it
from Mr M
or nice nice I'm sorry oh I I deserve it
I deserve it you got to you you were
took this with such uh great humor I was
so scared when I saw the the phone
message and then I and then I heard you
laughing on I go okay this guy got
it thank you you're like that you're
like that genius hacker you're the
genius hacker with the
glasses thanks
dub talk to you soon up next will Jen Z
go far if they can't drive a
car that was good hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else